خرج الالاف من اليمنيين بعد ساعات من
الغارات التحالف الثنائي البريطاني
الامريكي والذي
استهدف عده اهداف عسكريه قال المتحدث
العسكري باسم جماعه انصار الله انه استهدف
ما يقارب 73 غاره فييها خلال هذه الغاره
راح او اسفرت على قتلى وجرحى في خلال هذه
الغارات لكن هذه الغارات لم تثني الالاف
للخروج والتاكيد
دعمهم ومساندتهم لاخوانهم في غزه وان تلك
الغارات لن تثنيهم في المضي قدما و
مطالبين جماعه انصار الله لاستمرار
عملياتهم البحريه وايضا لاطلاق المسيرات
والصواريخ الى اهداف اسرائيليه حتى يرفع
الحصار وينتهي العدوان وتنتهي الجرائم
التي ترتكبها اسرائيل ايضا اكد المجلس
السياسي الاعلى التابع لجماعه انصار
الله المصالح البريطانيه والامريكيه اصبحت
اهدافا مشروعه لاستهدافها بعد غارات
البارحه محمد العطاب قناه الجزيره من
ميدان السبين
صنعاء